[Music]
Dwayne The Rock Johnson is absolutely
smashing the action movie genre with
some of the biggest box office hits up
next for the WWE star is Black Adam
which officially picked up filming in
April 2021 after numerous Stallings
let's break down all the ways Johnson
got ready for Black Adam
for Johnson prepping for Black Adam
doesn't just include sculpting his body
he's also studied the lore and origins
of the infamous DC Comics villain
Johnson noted in a February 2021
Instagram post that he enjoyed learning
the mythology behind the character which
he described as fun we also know he
prepped by studying a lengthy script
which he showed a copy of on his
Instagram page complete with watermarks
of his initials three weeks away from
filming Johnson noted he was up past
midnight learning his lines ready to
give us the best Black Adam he can he's
constantly repeating his character's
Mantra on social media amping up fans
around the globe who are finally excited
to see him on screen well I'd love to
wear a rainbow every day and tell the
world that everything's okay but I'll
try to carry off a little Darkness on my
back till things are brighter
I'm the man
anyone who follows Johnson on Instagram
knows that much of his time is spent in
the iron Paradise this is the name given
to his gym which he's reconstructed at
all of his homes in addition to the
traveling gym that comes with him when
he's on location filming different
movies Johnson has noted several times
on his feed that the iron Paradise
contains around 40 000 pounds of steel
and iron and the setup is a necessity
for him when preparing for a project
according to garage gym reviews The Iron
Paradise normally seen on his Instagram
feed is at his Miami residence though he
also has a nearly identical gym on his
Virginia Ranch the gym is equipped with
dumbbells that go up to 150 pounds as
well as 12-sided iron grip plates the
iron Paradise also includes a kabuki
Transformer bar as well as equipment
made by Star Trek what's not in the iron
Paradise is just as important as what is
Johnson's gym is free of televisions
mirrors towels and even water stations
when the actor hits the floor it's got
time time there's no room for
distractions or vanity
Johnson isn't a one and done when it
comes to stepping into the iron Paradise
he's all about two a days and sometimes
three a days the actor is in and out of
his gym constantly with no time of the
day off limits he always starts his
training days the same way with a
morning cardio workout these morning
cardio sessions are absolutely crucial
to the rest of his day in the gym and he
has no issues waking up at the crack of
dawn to get things going
Johnson goes back and forth between 30
to 50 minutes on either the treadmill or
elliptical which sends him into a solid
sweat Johnson told bodybuilding in
mid-2020 I love putting in that hard
work as early as possible to get my day
started off on the right foot mentally
and physically I usually smash out about
30 to 50 minutes on the elliptical cross
trainer first thing in the morning
whether I'm at home or at a hotel after
drinking a cup of coffee but when I'm at
home I like to hit the road as well and
after cardio I eat breakfast
Johnson is in the gym six days a week
which means there isn't enough time to
dedicate a whole day to one zone of his
body therefore the superstar has
mastered the art of the split workout
each day Johnson will focus on two to
three body zones and put all his energy
into getting those areas to their Peak
since Black Adam is remarkably shredded
even among the toned physiques of most
Comic Book Heroes Johnson can't slack
the actor really prepped for the DC
movie during quarantine in 2020 sharing
his weekly split workout with his over
341 million Instagram followers after
his morning cardio sessions Johnson
breaks down each of his days as follows
Monday chest calves and abdomen Tuesday
back neck and abdomen Wednesday deltoids
and abdomen Thursday arms calves and
abdomen Friday chest back and abdomen
Saturday legs calves and you guessed it
abdomen
in one of his official Black Adam
training Instagram posts Johnson broke
down his entire workout for his chest as
well as his triceps for the former the
actor does three giant sets with four
exercises per set to hit all parts of
his chest the sets start with fly
movements which involve fully extending
the arms and rotating them in circles
while keeping the elbows from bending
following that up are chest presses then
incline presses and then the real killer
body weight dips regarding the bod dips
Johnson says the work is very hard but
it's why we play the game he notes that
rest between these workouts should be
minimal or only long enough for a brief
recovery
in a midnight training session for Black
Adam Johnson explained his entire leg
workout on Instagram he noted that this
is his hardest workout which is why he
saves it for last on Saturdays the
Ballers star made sure to tell his fans
that stretching before leg days is
imperative suggesting 20 to 30 minutes
when you're tackling a workout this
intense these giant sets start with a
leg extension and curls and are followed
by compound pressing movements chain
lunges shark pit squats and barbell
squats in regards to the leg sets he
said multiple rounds of these giant sets
these are a real so get your mind right
and push yourself then it's time to
focus on his hamstrings and calves he
said it's a lot of hard work especially
balancing everything else life throws
our way but I really enjoy the challenge
of new goals new things to build pushing
myself it gets my blood going
Johnson's shoulder days are all about
maximizing the blood volume which he
noted in an Instagram post dedicated to
that area of his body Johnson says it's
all to fine tune and stretch the muscles
which need to keep their fullness and
their hardness especially given his
strict diet according to muscle and
fitness these shoulder workouts include
dumbbell lateral raises Easy Bar front
raises shoulder presses and a second set
of lateral and bar front raises to
follow this specific workout was
tailored by Johnson's personal trainer
Dave rienzi rienzi designs his buddy's
workout specifically for The Rock's body
and his needs depending on the film he's
shooting in a post the trainer shared on
his own Instagram timeline he reminds
his followers that not everyone should
attempt these rigorous workouts rienzi
stated DJ's content is created through
an actual workout that I structure in
advance depending upon his physical
state the famous Hollywood trainer has
also worked with the likes of Henry
Cavill as he geared up to play Superman
S Johnson heads to the iron Paradise on
Mondays to quote clang and bang as he
says he prepares for all super sets for
his back and biceps according to Men's
Health this back workout consists of
pull-ups dumbbell bent over rows lat
pull-downs seated cable rows and
dumbbell shrugs for his biceps it's all
about the reverse curls spider curls
standing bicep curls and tricep
extensions to finish it out Johnson
calls it a quote insane pump and intense
workout Johnson has made it clear that
he starts his morning cardio off on an
empty stomach so that means there's a
lot of intake after his second workout
of the day the first thing he inhales is
his recovery beverage which includes 65
to 70 grams of protein powder 35 grams
of carbohydrates one whole apple one
scoop of electrolytes creatine water and
ice Johnson reminded his fans don't
overlook the importance of getting in
your protein carb sugar immediately
after your workout it's that critical
time where your muscles will optimally
absorb these nutrients after you've
turned them muscles down from your
workout about an hour after he drinks
his smoothie Johnson will have his last
meal of the night which he says is
rather boring this includes chicken
breast greens and 2 cups of rice which
leads us to one of the biggest factors
in prepping for Black Adam the diet
Johnson's diet is just as imperative to
his prep for Black Adam as his workouts
are and he's got the science down to a T
when talking with bodybuilding he broke
down his meals and what some of the most
important Staples are when it comes to
his diet
diet wise I generally eat five meals a
day I'm very prepared and organized and
everything is planned out in advance
it's all measured depending on what I'm
training to achieve he also broke down
some of his Staples in the kitchen
saying the other Staples in my diet
include chicken steak fillets egg whites
oatmeal broccoli halibut rice asparagus
baked potato leafy salads Peppers
mushrooms and onions and then also some
casein protein in a March 2021 Instagram
post Johnson said that all of his food
is weighed and measured so all his quote
conditioning can come in on point a
traditional breakfast during Black Adam
training for Johnson includes whole eggs
and egg whites beef tenderloin oatmeal
and blueberries and gluten-free Ezekiel
English Muffins with smart butter
Johnson's followers on Instagram have
come to love his cheat meal posts where
he shares the absolutely insane
over-the-top indulgences as he finally
gets to scarf down after waiting all
week cheat meals come on Sundays his day
off in the gym and can be for any meal
of the day these meals are so important
to someone like Johnson training for a
huge role as they offer a sense of
normalcy in a time otherwise dedicated
to rigorously strengthening your body
part dozens of posts on his Instagram
feed Johnson's cheat meals often include
several pounds of sushi double
cheeseburgers peanut butter pancakes ice
cream various cookies turkey subs and
fudge brownies the actor loves a quote
midnight sugar train which is evident in
the choice of many sweet delights his
Cravings also change based on where he's
currently residing as he has many
favorite local hot spots cheers
with only so many hours in the day
Johnson needs to plan out his 24 hours
carefully and that means cutting back on
sleep the actor has to make sure there's
no wasted time meaning he only allows
himself about three to five hours of
sleep a night according to an interview
with variety Johnson said the only thing
that's regimented is I have to wake up
before the sun gets up and I have my two
hours alone when no one else is up and
the house is quiet I often sacrifice two
hours of sleep just so I can have the
quiet two hours that I need before the
whole house wakes up including the
animals during this time alone he likes
to meditate and lay out his plans for
the day he also mentioned that time
alone is crucial to prepping himself
mentally
recovery doesn't just mean a cool down
period after leg presses but also how
Johnson takes care of his body as a
whole while he's known for sharing his
workouts and cheat meals on Instagram
the action star also shares photos of
himself taking care of his body in
special ways in an Instagram post where
he showed off the gnarly circles on his
back after a round of cupping treatment
Johnson used one of his mottos we only
get one body so we gotta take care of it
the more he can heal his body and keep
it feeling fresh the more he can push it
in the gym giving us the best Black Adam
we can get in a post where he documented
an acupuncture session the Superstar
also mentioned all the issues his body
has faced over the years and why taking
time out to heal is so important
maintaining one's mental health is
critical and Johnson takes it seriously
while embracing a new role or business
venture the actor takes time out of his
very busy schedule to get some much
needed family time with his children and
wife while he tackles his preparation
for Black Adam every once in a while
Johnson posts a sweet video with himself
and one of his daughters on social media
do we have peanut butter flavor
great in one of The Rock's funniest
Instagram posts the girls try to figure
out what's wrong with his calloused
hands
[Music]
thank you